- [Voiceover] Let's say that we have
the differential equation
dy dx or the derivative
of y with respect to x is
equal to negative x over y.
Let's say we don't know how
to find the solutions to this,
but we at least want to get a sense
of what the solutions might look like.
And to do that what we
could do is we could look
at a coordinate plane, so
let me draw some axes here.
So let me draw relatively
straight line alright.
So that's my y-axis and this is my x-axis.
Let me mark this as one, that's
two, that's negative one,
negative two, one, two,
negative one, and negative two.
And what I could do is since
this differential equation
is just in terms of xs and
ys and first derivatives
of y with respect to x, I
could sample points on the
coordinate plane, I could look
at the x and y coordinates
substitute them in here, figure out
what the slope is going to be.
And then I could visualize
the slope if a solution
goes through that point what
the slope needs to be there
and I can visualize that
with a line segment,
a little small line segment that has
the same slope as the slope in question.
So let's actually do that.
So let me setup a little table here.
I'm going to do a little table here
to do a bunch of x and y values.
Once again I'm just sampling some points
on the coordinate plane
to be able to visualize.
So x, y and this is dy dx.
So let's say when x is zero and y is one,
what is the derivative
of y with respect to x?
It's going to be negative zero over one
so it's just going to be zero.
And so at the point zero one
if a solution goes through
this point its slope is going to be zero.
And so we can visualize
that by doing a little
horizontal line segment right there.
So let's keep going.
What about when x is one and y is one?
Well then dy dx, the derivative
of y with respect to x
is negative one over one, so
it's going to be negative one.
So at the point one comma
one if a solution goes
through that point, it would
have a slope of negative one.
And so I draw a little line segment
that has a slope of negative one.
Let me do this in a new color.
What about when x is one and y is zero?
Well then it's negative one over zero,
so this is actually
undefined, but it's a clue
that maybe the slope there
if you had a tangent line
at that point, maybe it's vertical.
So I'll put that as a
question mark, vertical there.
So maybe it's something
like that if you actually
did have, I guess it
wouldn't be a function,
if you had some kind of
relation that went through it,
but let's not draw that just yet.
But let's try some other points.
Let's try the point
negative one negative one.
So now we have negative negative one,
which is one, over negative one.
Well you'd have a slope
of negative one here.
So negative one negative one
you'd have a slope of negative one.
What about if you had one negative one?
Well now it's negative one over
negative one, your slope is now one.
So one negative one, if a
solution goes through this
its slope would look like that.
And we could keep going, we
could even do two negative two.
That's going to have a
slope of one as well.
If you did positive two positive two,
that would be negative two over two.
You'd have a slope of
negative one right over here.
And so we could do a bunch
of points, just keep going.
Now I'm just doing them in my head,
I'm not going on the table.
But you get a sense of
what's going on here.
Here you're slope, what if
it was negative one one?
It's going to have a slope of one.
So at this point your
slope negative one one
so negative negative one is one over one,
so you're going to have a slope like that.
At negative two two same exact idea,
it would look like that.
And so when you keep
drawing these line segments
over these kind of sample
points in the cartesian
or in the x-y plane, you
start to get a sense of
well what would a solution have to do.
And you can start to visualize
that hey maybe a solution
would have to do something like this.
This would be a solution,
so maybe it would
have to do something like this.
Or if we're looking only at
functions and not relations
I'll make it so it's very clear.
So maybe it would have to
do something like this.
Or if the function started
here based on what we've
seen so far maybe it would
have to do something like this.
Or if this were a point
on the function over here,
it would have to do something like this.
And once again I'm doing this based on
what the slope field is telling me.
So this field that I'm
creating where I'm sampling
a bunch of points and I'm visualizing
the slope with a line segement.
Once again this is called a slope field.
So hopefully that gives you kind of
the basic idea of what a slope field is.
And the next two videos we'll
explore this idea even deeper.